okay so I'm high Stern I'm a graduate
student at the try institutional program
in chemical biology at sloan-kettering
and Weill Cornell at the aside so I
study computational chemistry
particularly I'll be talking about how I
use Bayesian inference in computational
chemistry chemistry but particular how I
use it to fit molecular models that our
models use models that describe the
internet intra molecular forces of atoms
and these models are important when
studying the dynamics of proteins or
other macro macromolecules and they're
also really important in drug discovery
which will be the focus which the that
utility is the focus of what I'm
developing this for so just a little
outline what I'll be talking about so
first I'll discuss how these models are
used in drug discovery and then I'll
talk about Bayesian inference of the
model parameters and model selection and
I'll how I did that with PIME C and and
then I'll briefly I don't think there'll
be too much time for this but I'll
briefly talk on touch upon R awaiting
and error propagation using the
posterior okay so biological
macromolecules are the molecular
machines of life and they're involved in
many different functions such as
structural signaling transports
catalysts regulations bio synthesis when
there are perturbations in these
molecules that can lead to a disease
state and small molecules can be used to
mitigate the disease state by either by
interacting with a protein either
turning it on or off there are other
ways to do therapy but this is a very
one of the one canonical way that small
molecules interact with proteins and
disease states however while there are
many success stories of drug discovery
many of them usually end in failure
so this graph the y axis here shows how
many the number of drugs that were
developed using per billion
u.s.
dollars over the years and as you can
clearly see this process has been
becoming increasingly inefficient the
current estimate I mean it has been
estimated that the cost of developing a
new drug doubles every nine years and
the current estimate of drugs of of the
drug development process is 2.6 billion
dollars per drug this includes all the
failures but it's still an astronomical
amount to get a new drug on the mountain
and on the market and even when you look
at the drugs that do get on to the
market very most of them are not are not
really innovative they're just you know
changing some of the chemicals of the
chemical moieties on the drugs - for
patent purposes so as actually gotten so
bad this was named new rooms law to
contrast Moore's law which describes the
exponential growth of transistor
technology so we believe that so the the
drug discovery process has the
preclinical phase and the clinical phase
and this process has a 92 percent
failure rate so we believe that
intervening early on in the drug
discovery process with these molecular
computational molecular models can
increase the efficiency of the initial
stage and also ensure that drugs that
will will fail do not enter the more
expensive phase of the drug discovery
process so what are these models look
like so in molecular mechanics
simulations which is the models that
we're using the internet intermolecular
forces are modeled with what we call a
force field the force field is annotate
a newtonian approximation of the
underlying quantum mechanics so the
reason why we don't do quantum mechanics
which would actually be the true the
true description of the system is
because it's just way too
computationally expensive so we need to
do so we need to use approximations so
these these models the in these models
the atoms are modeled as point masses
with a fixed charge and the vibrations
of the molecules such as the bond
vibration the angle vibration are
modeled as
as harmonic oscillators as a spring and
there's a K which is the force constants
that that controls the vibration and
there's an equilibrium length and these
so besides this this bomb term there are
many other terms such as angles
non-bonded the energy of the rotate of
the rotation of the molecule around the
central bond so these the the terms in
these these functional forms in these in
this model have three parameters that
need to be fit to reproduce experimental
data and then once you have once you
have this model parameterised you can
run a simulation and in this case we
have what I'm showing here is a
printable which is a drug used to treat
hypertension and you see it found its
binding site in the binding pocket of
the of its target protein and it binds
to it this this movie was generated
using molecular dynamics which is one
one kind of simulation was it was it was
generated by the people at well not da
Shaw but des res which is which is also
David John truss company
it's a computational chemistry company
and this was generated on their
supercomputer that they built that
special that has specialized hardware to
run these kinds of simulations so these
simulations provide us access to atomic
level detail of how the drug interacts
with proteins however this is more of a
qualitative understanding of what's
going on and what we're really after is
a quantitative prediction of properties
of molecules that we can use to predict
which if we want to design a new
molecule we can predict which molecule
will better bind to its target protein
so how so how would this be used in a
drug discovery process say you're a
medicine medicine Oh Kenneth and you
found some molecule some some some
scaffold from chemical scaffold that
seems to be binding to the protein you
want to do some chemical transformation
to optimize the binding
so there's a combinatorial amount of
chemical transformations that you can do
and so before you do that you can go
over to the computational chemist or if
the tools are available you can run
these calculations on your own and
calculate the relative binding and the
relative binding energy that describes
how well this this molecule will bind to
the protein and then you get a ranking
of some better binders worse binders
however if you don't have the
uncertainty of these rankings you you
know you can assume that the top ranked
drug will bind best to the protein
however when you do have the uncertainty
on top of that you can see that some of
them might be coming from the same
distribution so it's not actually a
better binder and as a computational
chemist you don't get that many chances
with the medicine or chemists with
making predictions before they lose
trust of those predictions don't
actually pan out so it's crucial to
understand what the uncertainty in these
predictions are and there are many
reasons why these these these
computations fail there are many sources
of errors that contribute to the
uncertainty so the first is the force
field which is our model which does a
poor job of describing the physics of
the system there we also might be
missing on essential chemicals or
essential chemistry and physics when we
set up our system that we not well
described or another another big issue
we have is a sampling problem because
the distributions worth trying to sample
our very complex highly dimensional with
many narrow wells so if we don't sample
the distribution well enough then we
will now be able to make good
predictions so several of my colleagues
in in our lab are working on other
aspects of this problem the problem that
I'm working on is the force field
problem as in trying to to get in trying
to parameterize these force feel such
that they represent the chemistry and
the physics and in addition we currently
don't know
how much uncertainty these models
contribute to our predictions so what I
also want to do is quantify the
uncertainty that these models the model
parameters introduced to our predictions
so how first feels currently made many
graduate students and postdocs have
given a lot of time for this and it's a
it's it's a lot of work in trying to
data generation is hard getting the the
right data and then trying to fit these
models to to reproduce experimental data
that that's condensed phase and then we
get some parameter said that we hope
someone uses we hope is accurate so can
a Bayesian approach provide a better way
to fit force fields so what we do is we
cast the parameter a snow to four of the
force field that's a Bayesian inference
problem so we use Bayes rules and that
provides a probability measure over the
unknown parameters given the data so
what we have is we have some either
experimental data or quantum mechanics
data we have uncertainty in errors
associated with this data and we set up
an error model as our likelihood and
then we add some priors onto our
parameters and then we can use on MCMC
or several other MCMC type algorithms
that the physical chemistry community is
very familiar with to sample the
posterior and then what we get are
multiple parameter sets that are
consistent with the data so this baby'll
approach provides us a very
straightforward way to propagate the
uncertainty to the computed properties
so first we compute the property that
we're trying to estimate with some with
some representative parameter set and in
my case i usually end up using the map
estimate for that and then i mean
normally you would recalculate this this
value with other with other parameters
of the parameter set however in our case
to get an estimate of this value is very
expensive because you have to run a
molecular simulation so we use r
awaiting techniques to estimate
this is this this value and then we get
a distribution of that value and the
width describes the uncertainty the the
the the width of this of this
distribution describes an uncertainty of
the computed property that that's coming
from the parameters okay so the term
that I'm going to be talking about is
the dihedral energy so the dihedral
energy is the energy of the molecule as
a rotates around a central bond so this
is just a simple molecule of beauty
stress address of the molecule rotating
around the central bond so as as these
parts of the molecule come closer
together there's a spike in energy
because of the repulsive forces and then
as they move further apart this would be
a low energy state of the of the
molecule so you can use quantum
mechanics to calculate the energy of
this molecule at different dihedral
angles which is the angles formed by the
plane formed by these three these three
atoms and those three atoms and you get
this curve it's just showing the cumin
energy of this curve and this curve okay
and these are just the or it's in
chemistry this is called the Fischer
projection of the orientation of the
molecules just a easier way to look at
these the the configuration of the
molecule so this is usually in most
force fields given as a Fourier series
so when I'm trying and so what I'm
trying to do is fit the case and the
ends of this Fourier series that such
that a reproduces the dihedral energy
the quantum can extend evil energy I
mean the reason why I'm focusing on this
part of the force field is beyond the
scope of this talk but I can talk about
afterwards why we started why I'm
working on this so the model so I wrote
I wrote this package called toward a fit
toward a fitted there's a lot of things
besides fitting the model and it tries
to automate the generation of the data
and then the relating but what I'll be
talking about
as the is the sampling and how I've used
pi MC and I've used pint that have use
primacy for this so alright likely it
has given as it's a normal likelihood
and the e IQ m is the QM energy for the
configuration I which is the data that
I'm fitting to the eim n is the
molecular mechanics energy without the
dihedral configuration and then for the
EDA he'd role is this function that I
had shown you previously the N is the
torsion types because there's you know
if the torsions are described
differently depending on the chemical
environment of the molecule the N is the
periodicity which describes how many
minimas the curve should have and the
Phi is the torsion angle of the III of
the ithe torsion so I'm not okay so the
cone is available it's warning that's
pre-alpha so there's still a lot of
changes that are gonna happen and it's
not really I mean you can use it but use
it at your own risk it's not fully
tested so currently I I'm not going to
show the code for this because it's
currently still in PI mc2 but it's still
useful to see how how this works so what
I do have if you if you go to the github
repo that I had linked there is there is
an ipython notebook oops let's get that
I can't really see what I'm doing
should probably mirror this because okay
so there's the ipython notebook that
first you know this just describes a lot
of the background that I spoke about and
what I'm importing you know of course is
madflip look for plotting I'm importing
the MCMC model class from PI mc2
I'm also importing C bore for this for
the time for the plotting afterwards so
in order in order to get this to work
you also need parmitt which is a
computational chemistry library that
allows seamless conversion between file
formats because that's that's a big
problem - and then the torturer fit I
import the toy model which is this toy
model that I had written for debugging
and prototyping but now it's a really
nice toy to play with
so you instantiate this toy model and I
mean the N increments is just how many
data points you want
I'm not sampling the phase and then I
give it some true value that I will try
to recapitulate so this time I will
generate synthetic data it's not quantum
mechanics data because that would be too
computationally expensive so generate
synthetic data and here's just showing
you and here is just writing out like
the random initial value that these
parameters have after was instantiate by
PI MC and and then I just give on the PI
MC and CMC model class the PI MC
parameters that's an attribute to this
toy model and for the back end I am
actually using SQLite plus where I just
added some extra some extra I'm
functionality to the SQLite backend from
from PI MC I'm not gonna go through the
sampling it's a little slow the reason
why it's slow is because it's PI mc2 and
also it's an older model it's an older
model that I had written which the
current model still using time c2 but is
still that's two orders of magnitude
faster so this is just a little slow but
it shows it makes the point
so first the after we finish sampling we
want to look at the posterior predictive
to assess the parameter fit it's usually
the first thing I look at
is how well can I recapitulate my
deterministic my my the the the how well
can I recapitulate the data that I'm
trying to fit so okay here I guess I
should just go through they said the
reason why I do this here is that I get
fonts that my font for my labels are big
because I can't read from far so so I
usually just do that yeah if you would
just want to have a look it's I used the
an MP l RC params the font size and I
changed that alright so as you can see
it gives a pretty good it gives a pretty
good fit the black is the true value and
the blue is using Seaborn this is using
like the last few hundred iterations of
them Sam C chain okay now I haven't
spoken about this yet I'll speak about
it right afterwards we can also do I
also do model selection with PI and C so
why I need model selection here is that
I have I'm trying to fit this various
series right and I want to know which
term which multiplicity term do I need
and that's a model selection problem so
you know I look at the on if I if I look
at the at the output of this and I'm
looking at the marginal posterior over
the models and I have six models that I
can have it can have one two three four
five and six and if you remember our
true model was a three and turns out
that one has a high probability so it
does model selection and the last thing
well there are many other things to look
at but another thing I look at is what
the posterior at marginal posterior of
my parameters look like and I do
recapitulate the right value it's 20
kilojoules for the K of 3 the other ones
are either 0 or they're not here because
because of you know those terms are not
in the or not on the likelihood okay so
now that we're through this
okay model selection and in PMC so why
do we need to do model selection here we
want to know how many Fourier terms do
we need to represent this potential
energy scan so currently con tools to
fit these force fields rely on chemical
intuition to choose the terms and there
are there are some physical rules that
you can use to decide which terms you're
going to use but it's it's extremely
difficult it's again it grows
exponentially and and there are many
other other convoluting factors that
make it not a straightforward problem to
just choose based on physical intuition
so how many turqu how many torsion terms
how many terms will I have per torsion
so usually the Fourier series we
truncate it at N equals six and the
reason why we truncate N equals six
as I said n determines how many minimas
you haven't the geometry of the
molecules that we work with usually do
not have more than six minimis so that's
why we truncate at six but that still
leaves us with 64 possible combination
of terms so we have to select over 64
models and this is only per torsion and
there are many torsions in the molecule
so now the PI MC me wall does not do
transdimensional um doesn't do it
doesn't take transcendental I'm steps
right so this is more of a hack that I
did but currently it's working so what I
so I mean bear with me a little bit as I
take you through this because this can
sometimes throw some people off so the
algorithm that I use is I introduce a
bit string and the bit string represents
the model so say my bit string is one
right and the bit string representation
you have a one where it's black and
zeros where it's white so what this
would mean is that when I evaluate the
likelihood I only evaluate the N equals
one term and say my bit string is here
in that case I would evaluate one two
and six and I wouldn't evaluate the
others and I and I define this as a
discrete uniform distribution and then I
use a bit
into likelihood - to evaluate the right
terms so it works but I ran into a
problem where okay I call this
reversible jump Montecarlo which it is
reversible - um just a different
implementation of it but then when I
looked at the deviance which tells you
how good the fit is because it looks at
the negative to log of the likelihood so
when I use reversible jump as you can
see it gets stuck in these metastable
States it doesn't mix well between the
different modules and these states are
are basically different models from the
discrete uniform bits string when I use
the model of 63 which allows all terms
to be on I get a much better fit now
this it's it's not better also because
of overfitting but that's not what I
want to focus on I want to focus on how
well this mix this this does mix better
and I was and this had baffled me
actually I was trying to figure out why
this is the case so why what what I
realized was that when okay so first
what I'm showing here is these are the
so when I'm filling here are 25 separate
runs and in the top the top right graph
I'm showing the traces of the bit
strings for each run okay and as you can
see as you know they they start out
anywhere and then they all settle into
these like three different metastable
States and don't really mix and the
reason why this was happening is because
if you think about how this was set up
you have your your k's all have some
prior and i have given it an
uninformative prior and the prior was a
uniform prior but when i had a different
when when when that term is off the k is
now sampling the prior right it's not
it's not it's not couple to the
likelihood so it's sampling the prior
when it's sampling the prior the
probability of it being close to the
true value of k is very low so now when
i turned when i when i sample a new bit
string that has that model that term on
the it turns on but the K is so far off
then it affects the likelihood so
strongly that it usually leads to a
rejection so
a very high rejection rate we're very
well acceptance rates so I was thinking
what how about I changed my prior and I
make my prior more biased toward zero
such that if it's closer to zero when
did he come from the likelihood it will
sample values that are close to zero and
when I turn it back on the value will be
low enough even though if it's not close
to the true value its low in other
doesn't affect the likelihood that much
so the acceptance rate will go up and
this will lead to better mixing and
turns out that that's what happened so
what I used was a Gaussian prior with mu
of 0 and as you can see the mixing is
really good and I mean you see how even
before the deviants they're all better
there's the one straggler here which for
some reason gets into some at a stable
state and you know it's stochastic so
it's well well probably will happen at
some point and I believe this happened
because of really bad starting
conditions it gets it gets into these
two states which are the two correct
states for this specific molecule that I
was working with I was working with
butane and the reason why there are two
here is because there's there's some
degeneracy in the model there is some
symmetry in the model which is again
beyond we can discuss it afterwards ok
so now I will touch briefly on
propagating the error so so the property
that I will be kept that I've been
calculating to to propagate uncertainty
is hydration and free energy hydration
free energy is the energy it takes to
remove a molecule from water and the
reason why I use this property is it's
very closely related to the binding free
energy and also it's very mean at this
point it's very straightforward for us
to calculate it and it's also become a
benchmark against which to test these
models against because we have the data
and we know how to calculate it and
basically what it is it's what we well
we calculate the Delta V what we're
calculating is the ratio of normalizing
constants between the molecule and water
and water versus the molecule outside of
water
and instead of instead of running many
of these calculations I ran one
calculation and then used exponential
averaging to reweighed to re wait into
the other forcefield
parameter models and in exponential
averaging what you do is you calculate
your observable and you take into
consideration the difference between the
two distributions so for a simple
molecule like butane I look at the Delta
Delta G which is the the error in this
Delta G from the forcefields and what I
find it's actually very small it's a lot
smaller than the experimental error
which is around 4.2 kilojoules per mole
but when when I look at a more complex
molecule which is this molecule here I
end up with a much larger error it's in
the tens of kilojoules per mole and this
is actually significant and this will
significantly impact your predictions
that you're making and this is only in
hydration energies so when you do
binding energies there I mean this if
it's tens of kcal for for hydration or
for energy which is easier for us to
calculate it's probably higher for
binding energies now this led me to
think about why are these errors so
large and this is still open question
so I don't necessarily have the answers
for this but why why are the error so
large so first of all we're using
quantum mechanics data is that the right
kind of data for us to use and the
reason I mean it's it's the one that's
easily accessible to us because we can
just calculate on a computer you don't
need a lab to do the to do the
experiments but on the other hand these
these quantum mechanics calculation
we're doing them in gas phase and we're
trying to simulate a liquid phase in
condensed phase so how well does the
transfer and I'm not I'm not I'm not
sure that that might that might be a
contributing factor or I might not and
another question is is the functional
forms that we're using in the force
field are they do they represent our
systems accurately adequately so these
are you know these are still open
questions that were thinking
about so I'll leave you with that and I
want to thank my advisor I want to thank
my program at NSF for funding and I'm
open to questions that's a good question
and I I mean what we try to do is we try
to give the medicine or chemists a good
understanding of how how good these
predictions are so many times the
medicine will chemists will go and say
well I know that these transformations
maybe are not that great but they're
very easy for me to make so I'll just
make it and test it you know that can
help with our models I think the point
where it's very important for us to have
to be really really confident about the
predictions when the chemical
transformation is very difficult to do
so what you have to scaffold hopping
where like the entire like base of the
of the chemistry is different so you
almost have to change the molecule that
you're using then then we we need we
need to be very confident so that is
where if if if we see that we have that
that our calculations are showing of
that one is is really better than the
others then we try to use that to
communicate that it's worth doing that
change but again you have to be very you
have to be able to communicate how
certain you are because you don't want
the medicine chemist to do a lot of hard
work and then come back and say actually
well you know it wasn't it wasn't that
much better
so answer your question yeah
yeah so I definitely do that
I used that as my initial starting point
there are some people that are looking
at like other parts of the force field
that are using that are that are
constraining their their their priors on
on those those values so I mean we we
use we try to use what's on the
literature to inform what we're doing
okay so I've been using PI mc2 where I'm
not using the gradient in PI mc3 which I
mean I I do want to talk to you guys
afterwards I mean I I I'm I would like
to use the gradient and I actually have
an analytic form of the gradient here so
and so I don't necessarily need to use
the Theano gradient and also my
deterministic is a little more
complicated than just than just what's
what's you know I I need to so I need to
I need to see about that and and and
you're right about introduces a discrete
variable which creates some problems
there's another way that you can do the
model selection it's still going to be
discrete but it might be better than
using a bit string and that's using
Bernoulli variables so I can go back to
that and I can explain why so
so in this case we have these bitstrings
right and when we're proposing a new
move we try to propose a move that's
close to the previous move right but the
problem is this is an integer space so
what that means is is that lets say
model 7 is very very different than
model 8 right so while it will propose
something from 7 to 8
it will probably be rejected because the
model is so different we use 6 Bernoulli
variables you're only switching one at a
time so that might be a better way to do
but that's still a discrete variable and
it still wouldn't answer your question
so no I haven't tried that and we
haven't really thought about that well
the problem is the problem is that they
have very different philosophies and how
the parametrized and what their
parameterizing - so I yeah that's an
interesting question all right
thank you
[Applause]